hizo un balance el presidente joe biden
de lo que fue esta misión para retirar a
los ciudadanos estadounidenses de
afganistán y a los aliados afganos dijo
que había enviado 6.000 tropas a
afganistán precisamente para este
proceso de evacuación que él calificó el
proceso de evacuación más grande en la
historia de eeuu dijo que 90 por ciento
de los estadounidenses fueron evacuados
en cifras concretas hablo de 5 mil 500
estadounidenses que fueron evacuados del
aeropuerto de kabul y cerca de 100.000
aliados afganos respondió prácticamente
la pregunta de por qué se había demorado
tanto en empezar este proceso de
evacuación y básicamente lo que dijo yo
bailén es que en plena guerra civil en
afganistán empezar el proceso de
evacuación en junio en julio o antes
había sido también un caos dijo que un
proceso de evacuación en las condiciones
de afganistán iba a ser un caos tanto
antes en junio el julio o cuando se
empezó a mediados de agosto
y obviamente a todas las personas a los
voluntarios a los veteranos de guerra y
obviamente a las familias de los 13
soldados que fueron asesinados en este
ataque al aeropuerto de kabul hace unos
días le advirtió sin embargo a isis acá
al estado islámico en afganistán que no
se va a quedar de las manos cruzadas que
aunque no tenga tropas en este momento
eeuu en afganistán puede llevar a cabo
operaciones militares como lo demostró
hace un par de días acabando con la vida
de lo que eeuu califica uno de los
responsables de los atentados que
acabaron con la vida de 13 soldados
estadounidenses hirieron a otros 20 y
pues generaron la muerte también de 200
ciudadanos afganos así que fue un
mensaje que reiteró varias veces yo
vayan en este discurso dijo que no se va
a quedar con las manos cruzadas que los
responsables de los daños y de los
atentados contra soldados
estadounidenses lo van a pagar dijo
también que pues se simpatiza con el
dolor de las y que ya era hora
definitivamente y acabar con la guerra
en afganistán dio cifras dijo que esta
guerra le cuesta a los estadounidenses
cerca de 300 millones de dólares al día
y que no va a ser el presidente que pues
envíe otra generación de estadounidenses
a esta guerra dijo que pues se refirió
incluso a donald trump diciendo que
tanto él como otros expresidentes habían
prometido acabar con esta intervención
militar en afganistán que no lo habían
cumplido y que él lo iba a cumplir él lo
prometió en campaña y lo está cumpliendo
acaba la guerra entonces en afganistán
después de 20 años que estaba al que era
percusiones se están teniendo todos
estos hechos históricos y claves en eeuu
me refiero tanto al arco político como a
nivel social verdad
sí bastantes repercusiones muchos
empiezan a preguntarse ya entonces que
si se acaba la guerra la intervención
militar en afganistán porque no empezará
entonces a acabar la intervención
militar en irak en somalia en yemen
incluso en siria la participación que
está teniendo eeuu haya bailén hablaba
que ahora eeuu tiene que enfocarse en
responder a amenazas que tiene hoy y no
amenazas terroristas del 2001 de hace 20
años y hizo referencia entonces a la
amenaza que representa rusia que
representa china sobre todo los ataques
cibernéticos que eeuu ha sido víctima
durante los últimos meses que han
generado tanto caos interno tantas
repercusiones internas así que yo bailén
pues fue claro diciendo eeuu ahora se
tiene que enfocar en las amenazas
terroristas que tiene hoy y no amenazas
de hace 20 años dijo que su secretario
de estado seguirá en conversaciones con
los talibanes en negociaciones
diplomáticas en conversaciones
diplomáticas con ellos para este camino
humanitario al aeropuerto de kabul para
que los estadounidenses los cerca de 200
estadounidenses que no lograron salir
puedan llegar al aeropuerto puedan
evacuar si es que quieren salir de
afganistán bajo este régimen nuevo este
régimen desde el talibán y también a
aquellos aliados afganos que pues no
lograron salir entonces resaltó
precisamente esta resolución de la onu
que trata de asegurar con los talibanes
este que este pasaje humanitario camino
al aeropuerto de kabul y sin duda pues
lo que se escucha cada por parte de
republicanos es esa preocupación está de
qué va a pasar ahora con estos
estadounidenses que quedaban y que
quedan allá en afganistán y esta fue
precisamente la respuesta desde el
presidente yo bailén a esas voces
críticas esa preocupación de los
estadounidenses que quedaban allá que no
que va a seguir comprometido para su
evacuación aunque no tenga tropas en el
aeropuerto de kabul que estaban buenas o
bailén como escuchamos y como vos bien
así es un repaso
defendió absolutamente no su decisión de
la retirada y también del modo en el que
se llevó a cabo ahora como bien vos nos
comentaba desde algunos sectores se
están haciendo determinadas críticas no
como por ejemplo acabar con otras
intervenciones de eeuu en otros países
es visto también desde estos sectores
más críticos digamos como un fracaso por
parte de la administración de iovine en
el hecho de bueno retirarse con el
talibán nuevamente teniendo el poder de
todo afganistán
claro porque precisamente la misión de
hace 20 años era acabar con la vida de
osama bin laden y con el talibán que le
estaba albergando al qaeda osama bin
laden fue asesinado después en pakistán
en el
2011 la guerra continuó diez años más
costándole eso costándole cerca de dos
billones de dólares 300 millones de
dólares diarios
a los
estadounidenses que pagan sus impuestos
al día y precisamente los republicanos
dicen que pues de esta forma de haber
acabado la guerra que le costó la vida a
13 soldados que hirió a otros 20 pues no
fue la forma de hacerlo él el líder
republicano en la cámara de
representantes- kevin mccarthy y varios
líderes y varios congresistas y
senadores están pidiendo cabezas están
pidiendo por ejemplo la cabeza del
secretario de estado- anthony blinken de
lloyd austin secretario de defensa e
incluso están empujando para que se
empiece a debatir
es empujar en la cámara de
representantes y en el senado
el tema del pitch mente a joe biden
muchos congresistas republicanos e
incluso
de un senador bastante importante de la
florida había dicho que yo bailé
simplemente no estaban capacidades para
seguir dirigiendo el país atrás de la
forma como es como trató y como manejó
esta retirada de afganistán así que de
parte de el ala republicana bastante
conservadora bastante extrema y ese
interés de empujar en la cámara
representantes y en el congreso y este
este este impulso por el pitcher sin
embargo pues ya quiere mencionar a
santiago que pues no tienen las mayorías
que en la cámara de representantes los
demócratas tienen la mayoría y en el
senado también los demócratas tienen la
mayoría por ese voto que representa la
vicepresidenta kamala harris así que
llevar a cabo impulsar este interés de
impeachment al presidente joe biden por
parte de los republicanos pues sería
prácticamente imposible en antes de las
elecciones legislativas de él
2022 es decir el próximo año antes de
eso no va a ser fructífero cualquier
intento de impeachment precisamente por
las mayorías del congreso pero sin duda
las voces entonces sobre todo
republicanas y más conservadores son
bastante críticas recordemos hace unos
días apenas el 13 el ex presidente joel
el ex presidente donald trump diciendo
que si él hubiera seguido en la casa
blanca que esto hubiera sido
completamente diferente que no se
hubiera presentado este ataque al
aeropuerto donde murieron tres estados
meses y veinte heridos además de los 200
ciudadanos atados